para muchos ucranianos haber logrado
escapar con vida de mariupol es un
milagro como en el caso de victoria que
junto a su hija recorrió en los más de
1.300 kilómetros que separan mariupol de
cemex dejando atrás la guerra salimos
con nuestro auto con mucho miedo y bajo
nuestro propio riesgo dispararon a todos
los que iban detrás de nosotros en fila
pero conseguimos escapar de disco los
que ya están a salvo en polonia como
victoria recuerden a todos los que no
han podido huir de una de las ciudades
más asediadas por el conflicto desde el
inicio de la guerra miles de civiles han
muerto mariupol yo espero que el mundo
entero nos escuche y empiece a ayudar a
mariupol especialmente a nuestra ciudad
la ayuda es muy necesaria allí la gente
muere y muere no queda nada para beber
ni comer a semis también recibe
diariamente refugiados desde jarc y otra
urbe ucraniana fuertemente bombardeada
por las tropas rusas y se opone a steve
phillips todo está completamente
destruido no queda nada y cráteres de
enormes y las explosiones son tan
fuertes que te entumas y mucho
llevábamos escapamos del infierno
y del infierno literalmente del infierno
más de un mes después del inicio de la
guerra rusia ha prometido reducir sus
operaciones militares en el norte del
país y cerca la capital no obstante en
medio de las negociaciones miles de
refugiados ucranianos siguen llegando a
las naciones vecinas a diario en busca
de una vida alejada de la violencia